¿Quién derrotó a la yihad global? Lo hizo el ejército estadounidense,
los soldados estadounidenses y sus aliados,
luchando en campos de batalla lejanos.
Y quizá llegue el día en que se les brinde el crédito merecido.
Todos estos factores, y muchos otros,
algunos de los cuales todavía no entendemos,
se unieron
para derrotar a una monstruosidad tan grande como el binladenismo,
la yihad global; se necesitaba de este esfuerzo grupal.
Aunque no todos estos funcionarán contra la yihad local.
El ejército estadounidense no marchará hacia Nigeria
para hacerse cargo de Boko Haram,
y es improbable que el 6° equipo SEAL irrumpa
en los hogares de los líderes de Al Shabaab y los derrote.
Pero muchos de los otros factores que contribuyeron
se han fortalecido. La mitad del trabajo está hecho.
No es necesario reinventar la rueda.
La idea de una yihad violenta en que la mayoría de las víctimas son musulmanes
está completamente desacreditada.
No tenemos que regresar a eso.
La televisión satelital y el internet están informando
y confiriendo poder a jóvenes musulmanes, en formas novedosas e interesantes.
Y la primavera árabe ha producido gobiernos,
muchos de ellos islamistas,
que saben que por su propia seguridad,
deben encargarse de los extremistas en sus poblaciones.
No es necesario persuadirles, pero sí ayudarles
porque no han enfrentado esta situación anteriormente.
La buena noticia es que mucho de lo que necesitan
ya lo tenemos, y somos muy buenos dándolo:
asistencia económica, no solo dinero, sino asesoría,
tecnología, experiencia,
inversión privada, términos justos de comercio,
medicina, educación, asistencia técnica para entrenamiento
para que sus fuerzas policiacas sean más efectivas,
para que sus fuerzas antiterroristas sean más eficientes.
Tenemos suficiente de esto.
Y algunas otras cosas que necesitan,
no somos muy buenos dándolas. Quizá nadie lo es.
Tiempo, paciencia, sutileza, comprensión,
son más difíciles de dar.
Ahora vivo en Nueva York. Justo esta semana
se han colocado carteles en las estaciones del metro
que describen a la yihad como salvaje.
Pero en todos los años que he cubierto el Oriente Medio,
nunca me he sentido tan optimista como hoy
en que la brecha entre el mundo islámico y Occidente
se reduzca rápidamente,
y una de las razones para mi optimismo
es que sé que hay millones,
cientos de millones de personas, musulmanes como el viejo imán
en Túnez, que están reclamando esta palabra
y devolviéndola a su hermoso significado original.
Bin Laden está muerto. El binladenismo ha sido derrotado.
Ahora se puede desechar su definición de yihad.
A esa yihad podemos decirle, “Adiós. Hasta nunca”.
A la yihad auténtica podemos decirle, “Bienvenida de nuevo. Mucha suerte”.
Gracias. (Aplausos)